- All right, let's finish
up this hour with something
super uplifting from social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(audience cheers)
For many women,
getting pregnant isn't easy.
So a fertility doctor
here in Irvine, California
wants to be sure
when his patients find
out they are expecting,
that they feel all the joy
that they deserve.
So this is how he shares the news
with every single patient.
[Group] You're pregnant!
(cheers)
(claps)
- Not only are you pregnant,
but you are massively pregnant.
(cheers)
- You get a baby,
you get a baby.
It's amazing. I love that.
We have this very enthusiastic doctor
and his staff on the line, right now.
Watching on NBC 4 Los Angeles,
everybody say hi to Dr
Larry and his staff.
(cheers)
What's up y'all?
[All] Hello!
- Oh, my gosh.
So Doctor Larry, you've
been telling couples that
they're expecting this
way for 40 years, right?
- Absolutely.
I can't remember a time when we haven't
told our patients this.
You know Kelly, it's an
incredible rollercoaster
that these patients are on.
From a physical standpoint,
an emotional standpoint.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
So when they finally reach that point
where things are positive,
we wanna be just as big
a part of their lives
as we can.
And that's why we do it all together.
- I know, I love that!
The whole staff.
That's so cool y'all.
It's a very special moment for
every woman to find that out.
You know, every father
too, to find that out.
So it's very cool that y'all do that.
- Well, thank you Kelly.
- Absolutely.
I love that you've been
doing it for 40 years.
I'm like um, a lot of them
haven't been here for that long.
(laughs) That's amazing.
I was like, wait.
Thank you so much, Doctor Larry.
(applause)
I'm liking your post right now.
We love y'all.
(ding)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate doctors
like you, who give your patients your all.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000, just for being rad.
(claps)
(cheers)
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] Thank y'all so much!
Have a wonderful day!
And thank you to all our guests today.
Joe Manganiello, Casey
Wilson, Danielle Schneider,
Stephanie Izard, Shawn and Sara,
ya'll have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.